[Music]
could you speak to
the malleability of people's
testimonies i'm just wondering if you
have other examples that you can pull
from and certainly in police
investigations you see this constantly
uh cinematically rashamon is a pretty
good example
but
i'd love to to hear you explore that in
any way that makes sense it just seems
that memory is
less reliable perhaps than people would
think at first glance
i think both observation and memory so
the impression that we get
is that
we're good observers we wouldn't miss
something big in front of us happening
right in front of us and second our
memories are are pretty accurate and if
you learn anything about uh cognitive
psychology at all is that both those
things are
just simply not true so there's all
these studies into what's called
inattentional blindness where you know
big things happen right in front of you
and the dan simon's basketball video for
folks that i know i'm talking about as a
wonderful example of it i did a thing
called the color changing card trick um
youtube was the first quarkology video
we did actually where you don't notice
all these changes that are happening
around you
so
the way in which observation actually
works
is that it's incredibly clever you know
if you were taking all the information
coming at you all the time you just need
to brain the size of the planet so your
brain focuses on what it thinks is the
most important thing
and
then if other stuff changes you don't
spot that
so we are very selective observers is
the first part
and second when it comes to memory
it's not like replaying a film or a
video tape instead you have these kind
of fragments and you try and create a
narrative around it
and the place i see that most frequently
is actually when people describe magic
tricks
so you perform a magic trick they then
tell their friends what's happened it's
nothing like the thing they've just seen
and in fact the problem is their friend
said it'll show me and now you're about
to do something which was completely
different to the the description they've
just had from their their other friend
so
yeah we we create this narrative often
if we're being interviewed by somebody
they can suggest details to us
there's some studies on paranormal key
bending where you put a bent key down on
the table and the psychic says look you
still see it's still bending and around
about 40 percent of people say they can
see the key still bending
uh with the seance work again about 40
50 percent of people would go with the
suggestions of the medium oh my goodness
the table's levitating now and they'd
come out and swear they saw the table
levitate
so our memory
is very malleable
as we try and remember fragments and
create a plausible kind of story that's
how it all works
and of course what's terrifying is that
often within the legal system that's not
realized by juries and they go well
there's a very confident witness there
they wouldn't have missed something big
in front of them or they must be
remembering what happened there's no
evidence that's the case
yeah it's terrifying it's totally
terrifying
it's just uh which
thankfully there there are initiatives i
think it's called the innocence project
which is focused on dna based
exoneration
i'm sure somebody in the
responses to this podcast will will fact
check that if if necessary but
it is it is both
deeply interesting right because of the
sort of
cognitive reconstruction that can go on
and the power of suggestibility to see
the fallibility of observation and
memory and it's deeply deeply troubling
also when you think about some of the
ramifications but what's funny about it
is we all suffer from this kind of
uniqueness by us we think oh it's other
people that aren't observant it's other
people that don't remember stuff and i
mean you know i've done loads of these
studies i still find it hard to get into
my head that would be me thinking the
table levitated or the key ben
so we we all like to think it's it's
everybody else's problem it's it's us as
much as them we're all very very similar
in that regard
you